hello
i'm dan
[Music]
so i shared on instagram that that uh
friend of the pod brogan graham friend
of skullnick brogan graham dropped by
the studio the other week
semi unannounced
dude
i mean right you're here
[ __ ]
i'm here for the computerized recorded
talking of thoughtfulness and good
ingredients
it's good to see you good to see you
dude thank you
in real life yeah all right so so this
beautiful story so um
and i don't know if we'll use this
because it's very top secret but keep
rolling keep rolling
um
all right
i know you're on a call right now is
this his chair
[Music]
oh
[ __ ]
hey can i do an ad for four sigmatic
am i even saying that right yes
four sigmatic all right for my audition
ads audition brogan's going for the 10
minute ad oh [ __ ] okay um
i feel like we should get started
what do we do
i've been dreaming about sitting at this
table so thank you for uh
rich roll podcast we didn't have anyone
to like do a pretty shitty job with
camera work so we put out a little
indeed clip st louis dan drake shows up
the rest is history day three
indeed that's how they found you isn't
it
indeed
wow that's awesome what do you think
about the name zuma
which for any listeners and i don't know
if this will go up on the internet ever
zuma is
adam's
[ __ ] yeah
we are brought to you today by four
sigmatic
it's like coffee
with mushrooms
i can't believe it for those of you who
listen and hear every week these cats
talk about mushroom coffee
i will tell you
i'm kind of like a little bit of a
coffee snob
and i was very impressed i was i was
very impressed
that's the best i can do
and if it sounds too weird
i can stay home you're just you're not
adventurous enough right open your eyes
coffee doesn't have to be just beans you
idiot too aggressive i'm pumped i think
um
for an out of the box first try
i think i did pretty good
mission accomplished we did it
we did the ads
it happened oh my gosh
dude you hooked him up before with the
size large
and that was when i found out that i'm
no longer on the left
are you in george are
i wanted to update you we decided to
change my daughter's name we're just
going to name her skullnick
okay
i want to let you know i auditioned for
the part
i didn't get the part so it's still
yours
i even lied i even lied on my resume i
was like yeah new york times forever and
ever afghanistan so many times
yeah look at this and indeed indeed um
that that platform that you can get
employees indeed helped us get this new
guy he's been at it for three days i
mean he [ __ ] hates it here
he's got to find a platform doesn't do
you have an option that can help you get
get rid of your job
well
that's all we got i think we have time
for one more screenshot look at this
but look can you look mad yeah there you
go
yeah i got it got it
so good to see you man thank you for
coming dude
i love you man i believe in what you're
doing i love you too this is this is
this is [ __ ] crazy you're welcome
anytime
[Music]
you